catwoman is a familiar face but you've
never seen her or zoe kravitz quite like
this the batman gives audiences a brand
new version of gotham city where the
dark knight has already been operating
for two years when the riddler rears his
head to root out the corrupt officials
who take advantage of the power they
have the film also sees bruce wayne
struggling with his parents legacy when
the riddler's mission involves secrets
from his family's past it seems like
this new take on the caped crusader will
take a different approach to the classic
story than the one fans are familiar
with pattinson recently opened up about
the role to gq explaining he doesn't
have a playboy persona at all so he's
kind of a weirdo as bruce and a weirdo
as batman and i kept thinking there's a
more nihilistic slant to it thankfully
this weirdo has a few allies on his side
to keep him on the straight and narrow
when taking on the criminals of gotham
one of those allies is more of a frenemy
a mysterious cat burglar who has ties to
the mob her name is selena kyle aka
catwoman and she's brought to life this
time by zoe kravitz back in 2011 zoe
kravitz joined the dramedy series cali
fornication which stars david duchovny
as hank moody a writer with a penchant
for drinking drugs and numerous affairs
while trying to keep his daughter becca
happy kravitz shows up in season 4 as
pearl the singer of an all-girl rock
band called queens of dog town and she
invites becca to join the group pearl
and becca get up to plenty of mischief
over the course of the series even
stealing hank's porsche in one episode
kravit's performance as pearl shows she
can have a lot of fun with her role
although the writers couldn't resist
making a joke about her famous father
lenny kravitz in the series pearl's dad
ben is dating hank's ex-girlfriend karen
van der beek and the troubled writer has
a meta joke about ben referring to him
derisively as lenny kravitz speaking of
dark how's lenny kravitz excuse me the
batman may be zoe kravitz's biggest
movie yet but it's not her first outing
in the superhero genre her first comic
book role came in 2011 when she starred
in x-men first class fox's first mutant
prequel zoe kravitz plays angel salvador
also known as tempest in the comics a
mutant with insect wings and the ability
to spit acid she starts out with the
good guys but things don't stay that way
and she ends up fighting her former
friends in the movie's dramatic ending
it's a surprising move from angel who
initially seems quite happy with their
mission to help mutants but kravitz's
work in the role proves that she can
hold her own against other huge stars in
a big-budget comic book movie the star
masterfully navigates angel's moral
ambiguity which is definitely useful
when it comes to playing catwoman and
the batman zoe kravitz once again proved
that she can work well in a big
franchise when she joined the wizarding
world prominently appearing in the
second film in the fantastic beasts
series fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald as leda lestrange
unfortunately it doesn't seem like leta
will return in future fantastic beasts
films since she sacrifices herself to
save her fiance theseus and her old
friend newt from the dark wizard gellert
grindelwald then again this is a
franchise all about magic so it's not
impossible she could return somehow zoe
kravitz also recently showed off the
true extent of her talent in hbo's buzzy
drama big little lies playing bonnie
carlson opposite the likes of reese
witherspoon nicole kidman shailene
woodley and laura dern in the first
season bonnie is in the background of
the show she's quite happy in her
marriage with nathan and gets on well
with his daughter abigail unfortunately
as more secrets reveal themselves about
the monterey residence bonnie's life is
turned upside down kravit's performance
really excels after season one's
shocking finale which forces the
monterey 5 to hide more secrets from the
authorities to make sure none of them
end up going to prison without getting
into spoilers the weight of bonnie's
turmoil causes her to push her husband
away and she even lashes out at her
mother when she comes to monterey to
help her kravitz really shows her range
in big little lies and according to the
critics she brings that same complexity
to selena kyle and the batman
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]